president trump is now on a speaking
tour with bill o'reilly you're doing
this tour a few events around the
country and trump made his case
that
conservatives should not oppose the
vaccines they maybe should oppose the
vaccine mandates but not the vaccines
trump said he's gotten the vaccine he's
gotten the booster and believe it or not
he ended up getting heckled by his own
crowd
this was going to ravage the country far
beyond what it is right now
take credit for it take credit for it's
a great what we've done is historic
don't let them take away don't take it
away from ourselves you're playing that
you're playing right into their hands
when you sort of like oh the vaccine if
you don't want to take it you shouldn't
be forced to take it no mandates but
take credit because we saved tens of
millions of lives take credit don't let
them take that away from you okay so the
president made do you agree with that
right
both the president and i are vacs and uh
did you get the booster
yes i got it too okay so uh don't don't
don't don't don't no none
that's a very tiny group
it's a very tiny group over there
heckling me the rest deploy so trump is
in an impossible position
i know a lot of conservatives now are
just attacking trump because of his
coronavirus response
i'm a little lighter on him i don't know
a single politician on planet earth who
could have withstood the pressure i
don't know a single politician who's
being told that you will be blamed for
it that millions and millions of people
are going to die and you will be blamed
for every single death on every tv news
show from now until the end of time i
don't know anyone who could have
withstood this
once in a lifetime event being told it's
historic proportions the fouchies and
the dr scarfs and everybody coming at
you
i don't know who could have done it but
as a result he
is the face of that coveted response
and you'll remember at the time you had
nancy pelosi and joe biden and kamala
harris and all the big leading democrats
as the vaccines vaccine skeptics they
were saying i don't know if we're going
to get this vaccine i don't know i don't
trust a vaccine made under trump so then
the roles flipped when joe biden came
into power
this is regardless of what you think
about the vaccine or whatever
we'll get into it a little bit later i
think that people
i think there is a better political
response to this
which a certain governor of florida is
giving out right now but regardless
this is trump's biggest political
weakness
in 2024
this is the weakness
that he is the the beginning of the
coronavirus response the coronavirus
response up ended our country i really
don't think
it's totally his fault but that is going
to be it and if any republican
challengers want to come up against
trump in 2024 that's the angle they're
going to have to hit
i'm glad you like that clip now i need
you to ring that bell you got to
subscribe you got to get the
notifications that way you will never
miss an episode and if you want to get
the full show no censorship no watching
what we say around big tech head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play
maybe myspace xanga aol instant
messenger i don't know wherever you get
your audio podcasts subscribe to the
michael knoll show leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you